and the figure above pqrs is a rectangle
so that lets us know that these are
right angles right over there the area
of triangle rst is seven so rst is seven
and pt is equal to two-fifths ps what is
the area of triangle pqrs so let's think
about what information they've given us
and what we need to figure out so they
tell us the area of triangle rst is
seven so what is the area of triangle
rst given given these lengths right over
here
well triangle rst the area of any
triangle is one-half times the base
times the height so what is the base of
rst well we could view it as the length
of segment st
so the area is going to be equal to
one-half
times the length of segment st
put that in parenthesis times the height
which is the length of segment
which is the length of segment rs
so
times rs and that's equal to seven
that's equal to seven
and if we wanted to simplify this a
little bit we could multiply both sides
by two and so we could get the length of
segment st
times the length of segment rs
is equal to 14 is equal to 14 just
multiplied both sides by two two times
one half is one two times seven
is fourteen so this first this first
piece of information is that the product
of st
and rs
st and rs is fourteen
then they tell us
that pt i'll do pt in orange
then they tell us that pt
is equal to
two-fifths is equal to two-fifths times
ps
and let's just say for let me use pink
for i'll just use this dark blue for ps
times ps so that's that length right
over there that's ps two fifths
times ps so that's the second piece of
information
right over here i just rewrote it
and now what do we need to figure out we
need the area of pqrs of this entire
rectangle well the area of a rectangle
is just going to be its base times its
height so the area what we need to
figure out is going to be ps the length
of segment ps so i could write so we
need to figure out ps
times the height which is rs which is rs
times rs this
this is what we need to figure out
so going back to what we know so here we
know pt in terms of ps or ps in terms of
pt
here we have an expression with st rs
and 14. so somehow if i could turn this
st part of this expression if i could
turn this into something that deals with
ps
then i'm going to be in pretty good
shape now let's just look at this what
is how does st relate to ps
so let me write this over here so s the
length of segment st
is equal to the length of segment ps
it's equal to the length of segment ps
minus
the segment the length of segment
pt minus the length of segment pt
so i could substitute this in for st but
then i would have something that's in
terms of both ps and pt
but lucky for us we can also substitute
out the pt for something in terms of ps
that's what this does right over here
so this we know
we know that pt the second piece of
information they've given us
pt is equal to two-fifths ps so we can
rewrite this whole thing as saying
st the length of segment st
is equal to the length of segment ps
minus
two-fifths
times the length of segment ps
times minus two-fifths times the length
of segment ps and once again how did i
do that well we know that that is
equivalent to that from this piece of
information from this piece of
information here and what's powerful
about this is now i have st purely in
terms of ps
so if i were to replace st with what i
have in terms of ps i'm going to it
looks like i'm going to have some type
of product of ps and rs or something
that i can solve for the product of ps
and rs
before i even do that let's simplify
this a little bit if i have one ps minus
two fifths ps or we could even say five
if i have five fifths ps minus two
fifths ps
we get st
is equal to three fifths
three
fifths times
ps and now we are ready to substitute so
instead of having an st here we could
write
we could write three fifths
ps
three fifths p s
times the length of segment rs these are
all the three-fifths times the length of
segment ps times the length of segment
rs is equal to
14.
and now we could just solve for this
product what is ps times rs well let's
just multiply both sides times the
reciprocal of three fifths times five
over three
and we get and i think we deserve a drum
roll now we get the product of ps
and rs
being equal to
let's see what's 14 times five it's
going to be 50 plus 20 it's going to be
70. so this is going to be equal to 70
over 3
and we are done